So now that we know about ord and we know
about modulo, we're ready to define a hash function. So
let's remember what our hash function should do. So the
hash function takes two inputs. It takes the keyword, and it
takes the number of buckets. And it's outputting a number
between 0 and buckets minus 1, that gives us the
position where that string belongs. And we've seen the function
ord that takes a one letter string and maps that to
a number. And we've seen the modulus operator that takes
a number and a modulus and produces, as a result, the
remainder that we'd get when we divide that number by
the modulus. So now, we can use those to define a
hash function. I'm going to start by giving you a really
bad hash function. So let's define a procedure, and we'll call
it bad_hash_string to make sure we remember that it's really
bad. And it takes as inputs the keyword and the number
of buckets. And we're going to output the bucket based
on the first letter in the keyword. So we'll
use ord on the first letter, and we'll use
modulo the number of buckets. And that's our simple
hash function. For the quiz, I want you to
answer all the reasons why that's bad. And remember
what bad_hash_string does is take the first letter in
the keyword, turn it into a number using ord,
and then find that value modulo the number of buckets.
Here are the possible reasons, check all the reasons that apply.
The first is it takes too long to compute. The
second is there's at least one input keyword for which bad_hash_string
will produce an error. The third is, if the keywords
are distributed like words in English, then some of the buckets
will get too many words; others will get too few. And
the fourth choice, if the number of buckets is large then
there's some buckets that will never get any keywords.